from what i understand women can fall  into the men category once they finish  menopause and they are out of their  cycles yes let's talk about  the menopausal perimenopausal woman a  healthy age to go into menopause is  about 52 somewhere between 52 and 55.  many women are going into full-on  menopause at 43 and mid-40s when you do  that what happens now is you set  yourself up for the diseases that a lot  of women get later on cardiovascular  disease uh the breast cancer breast  cancer ovarian cancer with fasting what  i'm trying to help women see is that  when you learn how to fat when to fast  for estrogen and when not to fast for  progesterone and you learn like a rhythm  with fasting and you get yourself  insulin sensitive you will prolong your  period which is fabulous and it'll put  you into menopause at the appropriate  time to prevent disease okay well how do  we do it